you know he died on Friday while
covering the World Cup in Qatar Grant
was a CBS Sports contributor and a long
time Sports journalist he wrote for
Sports Illustrated for more than two
decades and was one of America's most
well-known soccer analysts now that's
the part you probably knew what you may
not know is that he was also a loving
husband married to cbsnews Medical
contributor Dr Celine gownder for 21
years and Celine joins us in the studio
Celine you've been to the studio many
many times we're always glad to see you
to talk about covet this is so difficult
to have you sitting here to talk about
this we are all so sorry so sorry I'm
wondering what you think when you see
the tributes coming in about Grant oh
it's so touching
um does it bring you comfort it does uh
to know that he was so loved by so many
people it makes me feel a little bit
less alone feels like you know that's
it's like a warm hug when you really
need it yeah like when you really need
it
how did you find out that he had passed
away I woke up to the news and I was
stunned you certainly found out before
the rest of us how did you find out I
was wrapping up one of my last work
calls of the day on Friday and I started
to see messages from Grant's friend and
colleague Gabriel marcotti's another
soccer journalist and I saw messages
coming in on Twitter on my texts on my
email and I realized well there's
clearly something wrong and so I got off
the call and I called Gabriel
and he told me he had seen what had
happened at the stadium that Grant had
collapsed that they had tried to do CPR
for some 20 minutes and then took him
off to the hospital
and two of his other colleagues were
following in a car behind the ambulance
and that's what I knew at that point and
so then I started to try to track down
somebody at the hospital to tell me what
had happened I kept on asking did he
have a pulse when you were asking doctor
questions because well I knew that was a
sign if he had a pulse when he left the
stadium that would have been a good sign
but no one would answer the question and
so to me that was I was scared I was
scared what have you been told was the
cause of death because you know that
there were Grant's brother came on and
and a lot of people were rattled by it
myself included when he thought that
maybe there was Foul Play here that it
didn't make sense to him because Grant
was very healthy can you tell us what
was the exact cause of death
yeah so he had an autopsy done here in
New York by the New York City medical
examiner's office and it showed that he
had an aortic aneurysm that rupture
means what okay so at aorta that's the
big blood vessel that comes out of your
heart sort of the trunk of all the blood
vessels and an aneurysm is a ballooning
of the blood vessel wall and so it's
weak and it's just one of these things
that had been likely brewing for years
um and for whatever reason it happened
at this point in time and how did you
handle the theories that there might
have been Foul Play
how did you process that I think
in these kinds of moments you really
have to show Grace to how people grieve
and my family my husband's family our
family has had a lot of loss in the last
few years my brother-in-law was there
when my father passed away
he was there to see the chest
compressions and the shocks he was there
with my mom shortly thereafter his mom
passed away then his dad
uh so that was grief talking yeah I
think so you know there's just been a
lot yeah I mean you know after he died I
started reading the articles that he had
written I started looking at some of the
tape pieces that he had done he was
clearly at the top of his field were you
a soccer fan
not really I'm not much of a sports fan
um I absorbed you know obviously some by
osmosis over the years with Grant and
you know would get into the World Cup a
little bit with him but you know that's
not what connected us really and so when
you see the outpouring from people that
knew him very well some of the tributes
that are coming in I know that you said
it's like getting a warm hug when you
need it most how are you getting through
this I saw your mom and your sisters are
here I'm so glad to see that how are you
getting through this Celine
yeah the support of family and friends
so I had two friends come over right
after I heard another friend came over
later on Friday night she stayed with me
she slept over two nights through Sunday
and she was the one actually fielding
all of the text messages the emails the
calls so that I wouldn't have to do too
much
um but everybody's just been so
supportive but you know what they say
about grant that because of Grant he
really brought soccer to life in this
country that he was so passionate about
this sport why did he love it so
I think for him soccer was more than
just a sport it was this thing that
connected people around the world
um there's so much about the culture the
politics of sport of soccer to him it
was a way of really understanding people
and where they were coming from
yeah you've been posting pictures about
with you and Grant and one of them I
didn't know if it was a joke or not but
the caption says this is a day Celine
proposed to me did you propose to him I
did I did so Celine you were forward
well I had just gotten into med school I
had decided I was going to head back uh
West to where my parents lived uh it was
my state med school and I felt like if
I'm going to ask Grant to follow me I
should be the one proposing and I'm
assuming he said yes he said yes and
then it was reported that you and your
family went to identify the body was
that important to you because other
family members could have done that for
you true yeah but I I just really needed
to see because honestly this has been so
surreal I had even now having seen the
body it's really hard to believe this is
real but I just needed that I actually
understand that I go back and forth
about how I would handle something what
I want to see but I actually understand
why that desire was so important to you
how do you want us all to remember him
today because attributes about him are
amazing
I I want people to remember him as this
kind generous person
who was really dedicated to social
justice you know I think that's another
aspect of soccer that was really
important to him that you know promoting
the women's game
um you know the recent statements he had
made about LGBT rights that was that was
grant that was Grant
why something tells me that's how he
will be remembered because he was so
beloved and so highly respected and
please know we're all thinking about you
today
and all just really willing you through
this thank you for coming you said you
wanted to come because you wanted to
share a Grant's story because believe me
we would have never asked you but we're
so glad that you you reached out and
said you wanted to be here thank you so
much thank you